it's a lifeline for millions of
palestinian refugees but the united
nations relief and works agency or unrwa
faces collapse without more funding what
happens if donations don't come through
and has it been stretched too thin this
is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm rob
matheson nearly six million people rely
on unrwa the united nations relief and
works agency for palestinian refugees in
the near east it provides food aid
health care education and other
essential services in jordan lebanon
syria and the occupied palestinian
territories now fulfilling that vast
mandate requires a huge amount of money
anwar has launched an appeal for 1.6
billion dollars this year
the agency has struggled to raise enough
donations in the past anwar says the
chronic shortfall could even lead to its
collapse now we're going to bring in our
guests in a moment first this report
from zenakota in beirut in lebanon home
to half a million registered palestinian
refugees
they've been refugeed twice in the past
now these palestinians from syria are
again homeless thousands of them fled to
lebanon during syria's civil war in
search of safety they're now struggling
to survive
the financial support they were
receiving from the united nations relief
and works agency has been cut because
underwater itself is facing a budget
crisis
they used to give us 100 for rent now
it's 25
they reduce the assistance for food from
27 to 12 dollars per person we can't
afford anything because everything is
expensive they basically throw us in the
streets
and that's where they have been for at
least a week
they set up camp outside ernawas
headquarters in beirut and say they
won't leave until a solution is found to
their plight
is supposed to be our lifeline but they
are not giving us our basic needs and we
can't go back to syria many of us are
wanted by the authorities and our homes
are destroyed
even before palestinians from syria
began arriving here unawa was
underfunded it was having difficulties
in meeting the demands of those in
lebanon whose vulnerability worsened in
recent months
palestinian refugees were living in
poverty even before lebanon's economic
collapse now many of them say surviving
is nearly impossible and they are not
the only ones the entire country which
also hosts hundreds of thousands of
syrian refugees is being affected by the
financial meltdown
onowa says it needs nearly 200 million
dollars to continue operations and meet
the growing and basic needs
unfortunately has been living almost on
a month-by-month basis and last year we
were very close to have to stop all our
services not just the additional
emergency help
palestinians have long been marginalized
in lebanon with limited rights and
access to services and job opportunities
i'm a teenager and i have lots of dreams
and hopes that i'm willing to reach but
because of what we're suffering here in
lebanon
[Music]
i always stress about my future
palestinians say they are trapped unable
to return to their homeland or leave to
go elsewhere nearly 80 percent live in
poverty the u.n estimates that's 162 000
people whose survival depends on aid
senator al-jazeera beirut
okay let's bring in our guests in oman
we have tamara aurafi who's a
spokesperson at the united nations
relief and works agency for palestinian
refugees in the near east in doha we
have marwan kabalan he's head of policy
analysis now the arab center for
research and policy studies and in
london ann irfan is a lecturer in
interdisciplinary race gender and
post-colonial studies at university
college london thank you very much
indeed for being with us
tomorrow i'm going to start with you if
the money doesn't come in how bad could
this get
if the money doesn't come in it would be
very very bad half a million girls and
boys will not be able to go to school
and two million palestine refugees will
not get health care so if the money does
not come in unera which is irreplaceable
in a region that's very volatile
might not be able to run this will
create a vacuum who will fill that
vacuum where will palestine refugee go
who will they will they turn to for
these basic basic health education and
social services
ann erfan what do you think the impact
is going to be on the countries that are
hosting palestinian refugees if the
unwar funding either begins to dry up or
actually ends altogether it's really
important to realize that when we're
speaking about refugee presence in the
host countries where enron operates
we're not only now talking about
significant palestinian refugee
populations many of these countries
particularly lebanon and jordan are also
hosting really large-scale syrian
populations that include twice over
palestinian refugees from syria so we're
talking essentially about a huge impact
that can go right across the scale
socially economically and potentially
politically as well here owner has been
a crucial pillar
of operations in these countries for
decades now and
we ignore that at that peril marwan we
heard in a report from zainab hodder our
correspondent in beirut just a moment
ago
one palestinian refugee saying that
because of the funding cuts the the
refugees that he knew had been forced
onto the streets now one would imagine
that the countries that these refugees
are in are not going to take kindly to
people being forced onto the streets of
their cities
yes indeed
i think the main problem that we are
facing here in fact rob is that anu is
very much dependent on uh on aid from
from foreign governments and that makes
it very vulnerable to political pressure
from these from these governments we all
know that
in 2018 for example president trump cut
the aid for the honorable and we know
that the united states for example
provides something like 30 percent of
the annual budget of the international
organization
uh and mainly because the united states
at that time wanted honor
under the
the the title reform
uh to deprive millions of palestinians
from their status as as refugees the
united states wanted actually to prevent
stateless palestinians from
passing
their status as refugees to to newer
generations and that will
prevent actually millions of
palestinians from
claiming the right for repair to their
to their rightful land in palestine and
or for for compensation and we all also
know that uh certain arab countries are
no longer actually providing uh aid for
the honorable also for political for
political uh reasons uh so uh in in in
my opinion i think the honorawa will
always be facing this dilemma as long as
does not actually find
uh other venues to uh
to to get the aid from uh this is
something that maybe we should think of
uh from now on i want to come back to
that by point but tamara i think you
wanted to come in at the start of that
i wanted to comment on what anar fan
just raised about under being a crucial
pillar of operations in the region it's
also a crucial pillar of stability the
predictability the reliability of the
services the fact that a palestine
refugee knowing that the palestine
refugee community is amongst the most
vulnerable in the region so when a
palestine refugee knows that their
children can go to unri school they can
get their health care at under health
services
this is one less source of worry so
unrwa has contributed greatly to that
sense of safety and security and and
even regional stability in the region
now
it is important to mention also that the
the role or the hospitality the
generosity of host countries the
countries that are hosting a large
number of refugees and this is something
that anne also um mentioned knowing that
all the countries where under our
refugees or palestine refugees live
are crisis countries themselves where
their own nationals are are under a lot
of are are facing a lot of hardship now
having said that under is very
vulnerable to the domestic politics of
its donors and what we at honorable find
mind-boggling is that almost every
country in the world votes for the
continuation of unrwa there is therefore
a political recognition at the level of
the general assembly that underwater is
irreplaceable that it is a beacon of
stability it plays a huge role for the
human development and the humanitarian
response in the region but when it comes
to paying
these same countries that votes for
umrah do not necessarily pay or fund
unrwa and therefore
the unrest faced year in year out is an
overwhelming political support without
the matching financial resources and
this is why we're always underfunded
and you were
nodding all the way through that um
tell me what you think
i think this is a really important point
that too often gets missed out of these
discussions that we're not talking here
about a one-off situation we're talking
about a particularly acute crisis that's
born of essentially a problem baked into
unreset up as tamara said whereby the
u.n general assembly issues unwrap with
a mandate to provide certain services it
renews that mandate on a regular basis
the vast majority of un general assembly
member states support the renewal of
that mandate but as an organization
owner is entirely dependent on voluntary
donations so there is a disjuncture
between the un mandating owner to do
something but not providing it with any
guaranteed funds that it requires in
order to do those very things this is a
fundamental problem which very rarely
gets gets really flagged up here man
this was a point that you touched on
touched on earlier but i mean given
giving cash um to organizations like
conrad and of course there are many of
them um might be seen as a moral
obligation but if governments around the
world are facing uh problems with covert
problems with their own economy natural
disasters in some some cases
is it is it actually naive to think that
they are going to be willing to actually
pay anything dare i say more than lip
service to something like anwar and not
come up with the cash and if they don't
as you were talking about earlier what
is the alternative
yeah
what i was trying actually to say is
that
i mean because
the honor is very vulnerable to
political pressure especially from the
donors um
that the people who are actually paying
the heaviest price of course are the
refugees in syria
and you know i mean the situation as
your guest actually tamara said earlier
the situation in these countries are
very very
miserable in fact because they are
having their own their own crisis but at
the end of the day you can't
prevent those refugees actually from
getting health or education or social
services which is uh provided by
honorable which will provide in fact the
safe
life-saving services for the refugees
you can't blame them at the end of the
day if we have some sort of
blowback
by cutting this aid and
as far as your question is concerned
i don't think that covet or any other
economic pressure that
donors might be uh suffering right now
from uh should be used as an executes
for these uh governments actually to
stop aiding uh honorable because there
is a responsibility by the international
community for this catastrophe which the
international responsibility somehow is
responsible uh
to a certain degree the uh the explosion
of the palestinians from there from
there from their land in 1948 and 1960
67
and
i believe um these uh factors uh are not
genuine in my opinion because as i said
earlier the political factors are the
main drivers for the donors actually to
put pressure on the anawa in order to
get certain demands
take for example the some gulf countries
and i'm referring here mainly to the
united arab emirates uh which decided
actually to cut aid to anorwa in
in 2000 in 2020 after the signing the
normalization deal with israel having
come under a huge pressure from the
israelis to do that so they actually cut
the it without any justification in my
opinion from more than 50 50 million u.s
dollars to one million dollar last year
maybe tamara has has the numbers but i
believe here actually is the issue is
mainly political it has nothing to do
with covert for the donors and has
nothing to do with other economic
pressure but mainly because of
political demands that are
these countries are trying to impose
upon enerva
to respond to
tamara given that funding is clearly a
constant problem for anwar and
organizations like it is there a point
at which they could be accused of
raising expectations too high if they
know that they're not going to get the
funding that they
so clearly want to get and and clearly
believe that they should be getting is
it
is it necessary for them to try to
rein in expectations because there is a
sense that people might see
organizations like anwar as
constantly failing because they don't
have the money rather than the focus
being on the work that they are able to
achieve
it's uh both of them so on the one hand
unrwa is not getting the money because
the donors are failing to come up with
the necessary money for umrah to conduct
what the donors expect on iran to
conduct as services so when the
international community decides that as
long as there is no
fair and lasting solution that includes
palestinian refugees underwater is the
go-to agency for their well-being and
the protection of their rights and their
assistance
then the donors fail to come up with
that money or
it's only a limited number of regular
donors that constantly support undera
and then end up feeling lonely in that
support which is the case now
then the onus is on the donors it's not
on underwater there's there's only so
much unrwa can do in cutting costs and
reducing its budget and resorting to
austerity measures to the point where
we're bursting at the seams
while the needs the humanitarian needs
and the hardship of palestinian refugees
in all our areas of operations keep
increasing
now having said that i want to touch
upon a point that marwan just mentioned
about the uh
the relations between political
positions and funding
most of our big and regular and
long-term donors are donors that enjoy
very strong relations with israel and
that does not prevent them from funding
unrwa because they believe in the
fundamental human development and
humanitarian role that unra plays and
they believe in their responsibilities
as responsibility as u.n member states
towards palestinian refugees because
there is no political solution that
includes them and so what we are telling
countries who used to support unrwa and
stop is that there isn't necessarily a
contradiction between your foreign
policy and international relations
towards israel and between supporting a
community that is amongst the most
vulnerable and who is entitled to
services by virtue of the u.n general
assembly mandate to unera there's no
contradiction a country can be in close
ties with israel and also support the
u.n in general and under in particular
and is there any organizational
structure that you're aware of that
might be in a position to to shoulder
some of the burden that anwar has been
uh tasked with because clearly it is an
enormous task that they that they're
facing i mean the one that immediately
springs to mind for outsiders like me
would be like unhcr for example this
seems to be
for those of us who don't understand the
structure there seems to be a natural
dovetail there that they could take some
of that burden away why isn't that
happening
unhcr and umrah operate under
entirely different mandates different
management structures as tomato would be
able to elaborate on this further
it's worth a briefly just outlining this
uh discrepancy between unhcr and umura
because particularly since 2018 when as
marwan mentioned the trump
administration
defunded owner we've heard continuous
misinformation about
the difference between unhcr and unra
there has been a lot of
false information propagated
notably by the trump administration but
by others as well claiming that umrah
gives palestinian refugees an unfair
advantage this is far from being the
case if anything actually unhcr has a
broader mandate than owner mandate is
relatively restricted compared to that
of unhcr
and the other thing that's worth noting
is that umrah is only mandated to
provide services to registered palestine
refugees in a certain geographical eras
so in jordan lebanon syria the west bank
and gaza but there are palestinian
refugees outside of those places we're
seeing this particularly now with
palestinian refugees from syria who are
seeking a sanctuary outside of these
five areas and when that happens in
theory at least they should be entitled
to receive support from unhcr instead so
the picture is a lot more complex and
involves a lot more
behind the scenes cooperation that is
often made out
more when we we heard again in zena's
report um earlier on that the some of
the refugees at least in lebanon had
been camping outside the headquarters of
onwa in beirut to complain about the
circumstances they were being left and
then demanding that something should
change but
it seems as though from what you've all
been saying that none of this appears to
be ivan was making the refugees don't
seem to have any action that they are
able to take other than going to the
people who have been giving them the
cash and now simply can't
absolutely right i think they should
actually demonstrate against those
countries actually who decided to reduce
their
the aid to to honor one in the first
place and hence leaving those people
actually deprived of their right to
education health
health care and other social
services and
make no mistake about this
we should always
look into the the greater picture when
we when we leave people actually
hopeless without
the basic needs that they need actually
you can't actually blame them at the end
of the day for uh
let's say taking different uh uh
sort of uh of of actions in order to uh
to provide for their for their families
and to protect their families to protect
their right in the first place this part
of the world actually i'm talking here
about the levant generally i'm talking
about syria lebanon of course uh jordan
is included the gaza strip
is is
is
these are countries that are stricken by
crisis economic political security and
some of them are having already civil
wars and the palestinians are in the
middle of these
of all these crisis
in the region
in syria as your guests have already
mentioned the palestinians have have
been actually doubled the prices um
because they are already refugees in
syria and they will force one more time
actually to live to leave the the
refugees camps that they were actually
living in so i believe here there is
this uh responsibility the
responsibility of the international
community to uh to to to provide honor
with all the
with all the means actually to
to keep those people at least with the
minimum basic needs that they need in in
countries that are really suffering very
difficult circumstances at
this particular
time of history tamara i you want to
come in on that
i wanted to come in with that with a few
figures um
that that that illustrate the hardship
73 of the palestinian refugees in
lebanon are poor 82 percent of the
palestinian refugees still inside syria
live on less than two dollars today 58
of palestine refugee families in lebanon
the grown-ups say that they
eat one meal a day or less to be able to
feed their children so it's it's
hardship all along and for um palestine
refugees who receive cash assistance
these are the most vulnerable ones only
the poorest receive between 18 and 25
dollars
a month
taking that away from them leaves them
completely desperate and pushes them
towards negative coping mechanism we've
seen concerning trends in jordan where i
am for example now it's increased child
marriage we've also seen the very
dangerous migration routes that
palestine refugees and other refugees
from the regions take we've seen early
marriage we've seen child labor these
are all very very negative coping
mechanisms that can only get worse if an
agency that provides state-like services
like unrwa
cannot cannot provide these services
we're talking about really an agency
that provides services the same way
a small to mid-sized country in europe
provides you know
denmark for example 5.8 million people
the population unerra 5.8 million
refugees in the region we're talking
about
a quasi-state that is
handicapped incapacitated by lack of
resources even though it has a lot of
political support and i want to come to
you last um because we have less than a
minute to go on the program so just
briefly if you could um
if onwards funding is restricted as it
appears to be at the moment
will do you think people
who are in the refugee camps that onward
currently runs
get to a point where they are forced
they feel forced
to leave those camps and move further
through the countries that they're in or
further into other countries are we
likely to see
the the mass movement of people that we
have seen in previous years admittedly
driven by war if onward starts to for
want of a better word implode
and very briefly please
this is not a hypothetical it's already
happened the the movement you referred
to camera moving towards europe and into
europe over the last you know few years
has included palestinian refugees it's
estimated more than 60 000 palestinian
refugees fleeing the syrian war
tried to reach europe uh usually by
dangerous roots so that's not a
hypothetical it's something we've
already seen happening and really it
highlights another inconsistency in say
the policies of european states who
claim that they want to stop what they
refer to as a migrant crisis
but they're not unwilling to say take
any action in terms of supporting enron
i know fine thank you very much indeed i
want to say thanks to all of our guests
tamara alright marwan kabalan and ann
irfan and thanks of course to you too
for watching you can see the program
again anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story
you can also join the conversation on
twitter our handle is at aj inside story
for me rob matheson and the whole team
here in doha bye for now
[Music]
you